.
Süsse Köstlichkeiten ohne Ende
auf dem Dessert Festival in Florida.
1'000 Waffelherzen muss Auswanderer
Mike dafür heute backen.
Doch ausgerechnet jetzt
wird seine Frau Marina krank.
* Sein Handy klingelt. *
Okay, und?
Ja. Und was ist es denn?
Aber noch keine Lungenentzündung?
Im sonnigen Florida eröffneten
Mike Hostettler und Marina Marrer
vor gut einem Jahr
ihr Waffelrestaurant.
You can have the Waffel with
Hershey's, Reese's, Oreos, Twix,
Snickers, KitKat.
Das Geschäft mit dem Süssgebäck
lief gut an,
aber die viele Arbeit
hinterliess Spuren.
Mike schlitterte in ein Burnout.
Im Laden sagte mein Körper:
"Stopp, zu viel des Guten."
Von einem Tag auf den anderen
musste Marina das Waffelrestaurant
alleine führen.
Man muss alleine alles noch
schneller machen als zu zweit.
In der Hoffnung auf mehr Profit
wanderte Bauernfamilie Wieser
nach Frankreich aus.
Es ist eine andere Perspektive,
und auch eine andere Cashflowmarge
auf der Milch.
Ihr riesiger Hof an der Atlantikküste
forderte sie immer wieder aufs Neue.
Das braucht extrem viel Kraft,
aber nicht mehr lange.
Auch Sohn Gian packte mit an.
Besonders streng
waren die Tage während der Mähsaison.
Trotz allem kam die neue französische
Lebensart nicht zu kurz.
(Französisch)
In Bella Italia eröffneten Philippe
Sguaitamatti und Partnerin Eva Dudle
ein Agriturismo.
Aber kurz nach dem Start
trennten sie sich.
Ich bin in keiner Art und Weise
auf einen Mann angewiesen.
Die beiden versuchten,
das Projekt auf freundschaftlicher
Basis weiterzuführen.
Entschuldigung.
- Ja, bitte.
Doch die Finanzen
und unterschiedliche Vorstellungen
wurden zunehmend zum Problem.
Und als eine von Evas Töchtern
zu Besuch kam,
brach der Konflikt offen aus.
Gut.
Thesi, wir machen einen Abflug.
Du hast gestern Abend gesagt,
du hättest heute keine Zeit.
Verdammt noch mal.
- Dann mach's du.
Wir gehen.
Ich habe mir meine Pension ...
... ein wenig anders vorgestellt.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
In Tampa, Florida,
beginnt ein neuer Tag.
* Entspannte Klänge  *
Mitarbeiterin Maddie öffnet
den Waffelshop selbstständig.
Sie ist eine
von sechs Teilzeitkräften,
die die Auswanderer
mittlerweile beschäftigen.
Hopp.
Für Mike und Marina
bedeutet das viel weniger Stress.
Anstatt 100 Std. sind sie
nur noch 50 Std. pro Woche im Laden.
Diese Veränderung war notwendig,
denn Mike schlitterte
vor neun Monaten in ein Burnout.
Ich habe mich
schon ziemlich gut erholt.
Noch nicht ganz dort,
wo ich sein will,
aber es wird von Tag zu Tag besser.
Ich bin zu 80 % der,
der ich vorher gewesen bin.
Komm, Djuni.
Zwei Monate lang
konnte Mike nicht arbeiten.
Seine Energie war weg.
Ihn plagten Verspannungen
und Panikattacken.
Ruhe und Medikamente,
dann kommt man daraus heraus.
Und darüber reden.
Also sich wirklich eingestehen,
dass man ein Problem hatte
oder hat.
Es war zu viel für den Körper.
Egal, wie lange das schon ging.
Ich nehme an, es hat
schon in der Schweiz angefangen,
Alles hat sich immer mehr angestaut
und irgendwann war es zu viel:
Batterie leer.
Eine schwierige Zeit,
auch für Marina.
Stellt die selber ab?
- Nein.
Auf ihren Schultern
lastete die ganze Verantwortung
für das gemeinsame Business.
Bei uns ist das Geschäft
im Sommer wirklich gut gelaufen.
Sehr gut.
- Ja, sehr gut.
In der Zeit, als er zu Hause war,
versuchte ich,
möglichst viel zu arbeiten,
damit wir Mitarbeiterkosten
sparen können.
Es wäre nicht drin gelegen,
ihn zu 100 % zu ersetzen.
Ich bin froh, dass es vorbei ist.
* Djuna jault. *
Djuni, was?
Jetzt, wo es Mike wieder besser geht,
sieht er die Zeit gekommen,
neue Pläne umzusetzen.
Der 45-Jährige
möchte wieder tätowieren.
Schon in der Schweiz betrieb er
nebenberuflich ein Tattoostudio.
Für uns ist es sicher gut,
ein zweites Standbein zu haben.
Das gibt uns finanziell
etwas Stabilität.
Die Bewilligungen dafür
hat er bereits eingeholt
und auch schon
ein Ladenlokal angemietet.
Heute kann er den Raum beziehen.
In derselben Shopping Mall
wie ihr Waffelrestaurant
befindet sich
das zukünftige Tattoostudio.
Mikes neue Nachbarn:
Kosmetik-, Nagel- und Coiffeursalons.
Oh, ist das kalt hier.
Seine Arbeitstage
möchte Mike von jetzt an aufteilen.
Einen halben Tag
wird er im Waffelshop sein,
die andere Hälfte hier.
Im Waffelrestaurant soll Mike
durch Angestellte ersetzt werden.
Für mich war eigentlich immer klar,
dass ich hier mit dem Tätowieren
weitermachen möchte.
Für mich ist es
nicht irgendein Beruf,
sondern ein Hobby,
eine Leidenschaft.
Und nach meinem Zusammenbruch,
den ich hatte,
habe ich lange darauf gewartet,
dass ich wieder starten kann.
Es gibt mir die nötige Entspannung.
Das ist Abwechslung
und Freude pur für mich.
Falls das Tätowieren Mike hilft,
seine Balance zu finden,
würde auch Marina davon profitieren.
* Rumbaversion von Göläs
"Uf u Dervo" *
In der Toskana
ist der Herbst angebrochen.
Die Bauern in der Region
ernten die Oliven.
Bei den Auswanderern aber
ist es noch nicht so weit.
Philippe hat sich mit seinem Gärtner
Massimo verabredet.
Sie wollen sehen, wie sich die
800 Olivenbäumchen entwickelt haben.
Vor einem halben Jahr
liess Philippe sie pflanzen.
(Italienisch)
Die Bäumchen musste Philippe
den ganzen Sommer über bewässern.
Jeder andere Strauch
wäre jetzt aber wirklich -
auf gut Deutsch gesagt -
völlig eingegangen.
Aber die Olive nicht.
Das ist so ein schöner Baum.
Da ist so eine Geschichte dahinter.
Es kommt nicht von ungefähr, dass
Olivenbäume 2'000 Jahre alt sind.
Die Olivenbäume
sind wichtig für die Schweizer.
Denn die Einnahmen
aus der Landwirtschaft
müssen höher sein
als aus dem Gästebetrieb.
Nur so gelten sie als Agriturismo.
Doch für weitere Investitionen in
den Ackerbau fehlt momentan das Geld.
Er wartet nur darauf,
dass wir den anderen Teil machen.
Im Moment ist es einfach
eine Person, die alles blockiert.
Das ist ein riesen Frust.
Das Geld ist zum Reizthema
zwischen Gutsverwalter Philippe
und Kapitalgeberin Eva geworden.
Die Zusammenarbeit
als Geschäftspartner
wird je länger je schwieriger.
Die Ferienwohnungen konnte Eva
zwar mittlerweile alle möblieren,
aber bei fünf der sechs Appartements
fehlt noch die Küche.
Und den Kauf mit einem Kredit
zu finanzieren,
kommt für Eva - im Gegensatz
zu Philippe - nicht infrage.
Ich bin 67,
ich will keine Schulden haben.
Ich muss hier von meiner AHV
leben können.
Wenn ich Schulden habe,
ist das bereits unmöglich.
Die fehlenden Küchen
will sich Eva von ihrem Verdienst
als Kindergartenlehrerin absparen.
Philippe möchte rasch
geliehenes Geld investieren.
Die Vorstellungen der beiden
scheinen unvereinbar.
Schau ...
... hier kannst du das Meer hören.
Bis an die Atlantikküste
sind es zwar nur knapp 30 Min.
Aber für Ausflüge ans Meer
hatte Bauernfamilie Wieser
in Frankreich bisher kaum Zeit.
In den ersten paar Monaten
mussten wir zuerst Geld reinbringen
und uns einleben.
Dann kam die Erntezeit
und jetzt wird es ruhiger.
Jetzt haben wir mehr
Zeit für solche Sachen.
Bald ein Jahr ist es her,
dass Aleksandra und Sandro
mit ihrem Sohn Gian
die Schweiz verlassen haben.
* Entferntes Muhen *
Im Aargau hatten sie
einen kleinen Hof mit gut 50 Tieren.
Hier sind es über 400.
Bei so vielen Tieren ist die Geburt
eines Kälbchens fast alltäglich.
In der Regel können die Kühe
ihren Nachwuchs ohne Unterstützung
zur Welt bringen.
Man merkt schon,
wenn man ihr helfen muss.
Wenn sie zu lange dran ist
und wimmert,
dann hilft man ihr -
also Sandro hilft.
Ich stehe daneben und schaue zu,
weil ... ugh, nein.
* Muhen *
Zeit ist knapp.
Und um die viele Arbeit
bewältigen zu können,
setzen Wiesers vermehrt
auf technische Hilfsmittel.
Aleksandras neustes Gadget
ist ein elektrischer Milchwagen.
Vorher habe ich Bidons getragen,
Milchkessel.
Und rüber geschleppt.
Das ist dann schon ...
* Muhen *
... darum ...
... TaxiLait. Komm.
Und noch etwas
ist einfacher in Frankreich.
Aleksandra und ihr Mann Sandro
arbeiten besser zusammen.
Wir sind hier viel zufriedener.
Dort gab es immer
irgendeinen Knatsch,
es war immer irgendetwas -
hier ist es wirklich ...
Wir sind ein richtig
gut eingespieltes Team.
Kannst du mir einen Gefallen machen?
Das Kalb hat sich verdreht.
Sandro muss bei der Geburt helfen.
Es ist nicht richtig offen.
* Leises Muhen *
* Angestrengtes Muhen *
Es geht nicht alleine.
Jetzt muss auch Aleksandra ran.
Jetzt.
Ho, hopp. Langsam.
* Angestrengtes Muhen *
Ein Riesenviech.
* Die Kuh brüllt. *
Ja, Schatz. Drück noch einmal, komm.
Jetzt.
* Sandro ächzt. *
Schau, deines.
Trotz Routine: Eine Geburt
ist immer auch ein bewegender Moment.
Und wirtschaftliche Notwendigkeit
zugleich.
Denn nur so können die Wiesers ihre
Milchproduktion am Laufen halten.
* Sanfte Klänge *
In Florida macht Waffelbäcker Mike
einen Grosseinkauf.
Ausnahmsweise ist seine Einkaufsliste
noch viel länger als sonst.
Ja, jetzt brauchen wir
eine rechte Menge.
Das grösste Dessert Festival
in Amerika.
Wir wurden dort aufgenommen.
Dort sind noch 49 andere Aussteller.
Am Schluss können die Besucher
einen Gewinner wählen.
Und es gibt eine Jury,
die auch noch einen Gewinner wählt.
Mal schauen.
* Gelassene Klänge *
Mike ist heute doppelt gefordert.
Er muss das Tagesgeschäft erledigen
und zusätzlich sieben Eimer Teig
verbacken.
Das ergibt 200 Waffeln
für das Dessert Festival,
zu dem sie eingeladen sind.
Ich brauche pro Waffel
1 Min. und 40 Sek., mal 200.
3-4 Std.?
* Geschäftige Klänge *
Mikes Problem: Er muss den Event
alleine vorbereiten.
Seine Frau Marina ist krank.
Mit starkem Husten
lag sie die halbe Nacht wach.
Doch kaum begonnen ...
- Is it for here or to go?
... wird Mike immer wieder
durch Kunden unterbrochen.
That's yours.
Cappuccino is the most ...
Geht es in diesem Tempo weiter,
wird Mike heute kaum fertig.
You wanna pesto
or sour cream by side?
* Türklingel *
Zum Glück aber kommt Dianne.
Hey, Mike.
- Hey, how are you?- Good.
You were right.
Sie hat sich kurzfristig
bereit erklärt, zu helfen.
Dianne war bei der Eröffnung hier.
Seitdem kommt sie immer wieder.
Ohne Bezahlung,
einfach, weil sie Freude hat.
Sie sagt immer, dass wir
zwei so gute Menschen sind,
die es verdient hätten,
dass man ihnen hilft.
Normalerweise arbeitet Dianne im Büro
als Buchhalterin.
* Sein Handy klingelt. *
Dann meldet sich Marina.
Sie war unterdessen beim Arzt.
Ja, was ist es denn?
Aber noch keine Lungenentzündung?
Was machen wir morgen?
Absagen oder trotzdem gehen?
Marina hat eine schwere Bronchitis.
Jetzt müssen die Auswanderer
entscheiden,
ob sie die Teilnahme
am Dessert Festival morgen
unter diesen Umständen
durchziehen wollen.
Über dem Agriturismo in der Toskana
ziehen immer dunklere Wolken auf.
* Schwere Klänge *
Die Stimmung zwischen Eva
und ihrem ehemaligen Partner Philippe
ist unterkühlt.
Was suchst du?
- Cornflakes.
Da steht's, neben den Dingern.
Die beiden sprechen nur noch
das Nötigste miteinander.
Es ist schleichend gekommen.
Dass wir kein Paar mehr sind,
ist schon lange klar.
Es ist eigentlich eher ...
Dass es auch hier nicht
miteinander weitergeht,
ist eher etwas ...
Zuerst dachte ich,
wir können das als Freunde machen.
Dann habe ich gemerkt:
Das funktioniert nicht.
Philippe und Eva
haben sich zuerst privat
und dann geschäftlich
auseinandergelebt.
Die gemeinsame Vision ging verloren.
Ich weiss es wirklich nicht.
Vernünftig wäre,
jetzt hier aufzuhören.
Und mein unvernünftiger Teil sagt:
"Mach weiter."
Ja.
Am Ende sind es zu viele
Unstimmigkeiten, die sich auftürmen.
Schon bei der Wahl der Liegenschaft
hatten die beiden
unterschiedliche Meinungen.
Auch beim Tempo der Umsetzung
oder der Frage der Finanzierung
lagen die Vorstellungen
weit auseinander.
Komm, Mädchen.
Ja, hoi.
Nur in einem sind sich
Eva und Philippe einig:
So kann es nicht weitergehen.
Es gibt drei Pläne:
Er kauft es mir ab mit irgendwelchen
Investoren, was auch immer.
Davon redet er jedenfalls,
ich habe keine Ahnung.
Die zweite Variante ist,
dass ich einen Teilverkauf mache.
Jemand kommt hierher, um zu arbeiten
und es zu bewirtschaften,
und gibt mir einen Teil vom Geld.
In drei oder vier Jahren
zahlt die Person den Rest zurück.
Und die dritte Möglichkeit ist,
dass ich es übernehme.
Du bist brav, gell.
Egal ob Eva den Posten des
Gutsverwalters von Philippe übernimmt
oder die Liegenschaft verkauft:
Einer von beiden
wird schon bald seine Koffer packen.
* Mehrstimmiges Zwitschern *
Besser läuft es
auf dem Hof Les Aubiers
nahe der französischen Atlantikküste.
Bauer Sandro investiert weiter
in seinen Betrieb.
Er will die Tiere aus
einem ausserhalb gelegenen Stall
neu auf seinem Gelände unterbringen.
Dafür lässt er bauen.
Florent.
- Hein?
Wenn man hier schaufelt,
ist es blöd,
wenn man hier den Dreck rausstösst.
Das gibt eine riesen Sauerei.
Wenn Sandro alle Tiere
hier auf dem Hof beisammenhat,
kann er effizienter wirtschaften.
Die Idee ist,
dass man rückwärts
mit dem Futtermischwagen reinfahren
und von hier abladen kann.
Aber hier sind wir etwas hoch
und dort etwas tief.
Das müssen wir noch begradigen.
* Geschäftige Akkordeonklänge *
Sali, bist du nicht mit Papa mit?
Wieso?
- Ah, Papa mischt Futter.
Futter mischen!
Achtung, Traktoren!
Trotz der vielen Arbeit:
Aleksandra scheint in ihrer
neuen Heimat angekommen zu sein.
Von Frankreich
habe ich noch nicht viel gesehen.
Aber auf dem Betrieb
gefällt es mir megagut.
Wir haben auch schon
soziale Kontakte.
Kuckuck.
Wir treffen schon Freunde.
Das ist wirklich noch schön.
Oui. Et toi?
- Ouais.
Auch Sohn Gian
hat sich schnell eingelebt.
Der Hof ist für ihn
ein riesiger Abenteuerspielplatz.
* Motorgeräusche, Piepsen. *
Oui?
Ben ...
Pour aller dans la champs?
- Oui.
Il y a aussi ...
Noch vor einem Dreivierteljahr
konnte der Neunjährige
kaum ein Wort Französisch.
Jetzt spricht er bereits besser
als seine Mutter Aleksandra.
Sicher sind wir stolz auf Gian,
dass er das so schnell im Griff
hatte. Der junge Herr.
Ich weiss, was da alles drin ist.
Aber ich kann es
nicht auf Französisch sagen.
* Rockige Akkordeonversion von Göläs
"Uf u Dervo" *
Ja, es gefällt mir gut hier.
Sehr gut.
Wenn es klimpert und klappert,
ist es gut.
So, Feierabend.
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Die Touristen sind weg
und an den im Sommer überfüllten
Stränden in der Toskana
ist wieder Ruhe eingekehrt.
Erst ein halbes Jahr ist es her,
seit Philippe ausgewandert ist.
Eigentlich wäre jetzt der Moment,
um nach einer ersten Saison
Bilanz zu ziehen.
Es ist irgendwie
so überwältigend schön.
Doch der Traum vom Leben in Italien
scheint für Philippe
zu Ende zu gehen,
bevor er richtig begonnen hat.
* Schwere Gitarrenklänge *
Auch Eva hat sich alles
anders vorgestellt.
So, ready for leave.
Den nehme ich mit, die bleiben da.
Für die Kindergartenlehrerin
sind die Herbstferien zu Ende.
Sie muss zurück in die Schweiz.
In den nächsten Wochen
soll sich zeigen,
wie es mit dem Agriturismo
weitergeht.
* Leises Quietschen *
Eva und Philippe
waren erst zweieinhalb Jahre ein Paar
als sie das Projekt
gemeinsam starteten.
Beherzt wollten sie dem Buch des
Lebens ein neues Kapitel hinzufügen.
Mir wäre nie in den Sinn gekommen,
von Anfang an daran zu denken,
dass das nie funktionieren wird.
Im Gegenteil.
Ich dachte, wir sind zwei,
die eine gute Idee haben,
die einen guten Draht
zum Land haben, usw.
Aber ...
... wenn es nicht klappt,
klappt es halt nicht.
Trotz Pensionsalter
wagte Philippe den Neuanfang.
Denn im Land seiner Grosseltern
fühlt er sich wohl.
Ich habe mich wahnsinnig gebunden
an die Olivenbäume,
an diese Gegend, an die Leute ...
Die Tatsache, dass ich
es nicht fertiggebracht habe,
den Enthusiasmus, den ich für
diese Gegend und das Projekt habe,
rüberzubringen ...
Das habe ich nicht geschafft.
In diesem Sinne
habe ich versagt, das ist ...
Ich muss es im Moment
wirklich relativ teuer zahlen.
In den letzten Tagen und Wochen ...
... habe ich versucht,
mich immer mehr zu entfernen.
Ansonsten zerreisst es mir
wirklich das Herz.
* Schwermütige Gitarrenklänge *
Ach, ja.
Wenige Wochen später
erkrankt Philippe.
Er sieht sich dadurch gezwungen,
sich aus dem Projekt in der Toskana
zurückzuziehen.
Hi!
- How are you?
Cool.
- Is it good?- Yeah.
Marina hat sich entschieden,
am Dessert Festival teilzunehmen.
Ich habe gestern
vom Arzt Medikamente bekommen.
Es ist eine akute Bronchitis,
bei der man nicht genau weiss,
ob sie auf die Lunge
übergegriffen hat.
Aber die Ärztin meint,
die Medikamente -
das Antibiotika und Kortison ...
Wenn es am Montag besser ist,
sollte es gut sein.
Sonst gehe ich nochmal.
Rocken wir das Ding heute.
Freundin Dianne
wird die beiden unterstützen.
Do we have more space in the car?
Auf geht's
Richtung Stadtrand von Tampa.
In einer Messehalle
finden die Dessert Wars statt.
Laut Veranstalter
das grösste Dessert Festival der USA.
50 verschiedene Süsswarenhersteller
wetteifern heute
um den Titel des Dessert Champions.
Noch ein Stück.
Es ist riesig, v.a. haben wir
einen coolen Platz gleich am Anfang.
Marina und Mike
müssen 100 Waffelherzen vorbereiten
als Kostprobe für Besucher und Jury.
Bevor es los geht, schnell noch
ein Blick auf die Konkurrenz.
Hast du gesehen?- Das sind
natürlich kleinere Samples.
Da hast du schnell mal 1'000.
Man sieht auch,
welche Unternehmen mehr Geld haben.
Von der Aufmachung her.
Aber es ist cool.
Das ist unser erstes Event.
Wir können auch etwas abschauen.
Sie sagten, dass wir nächstes Mal
wieder kommen müssen.
Sie nehmen immer wieder
die gleichen, das ist noch cool.
Die Jury schaut sich schon um
und bewertet.
Zehn Jurorinnen und Juroren bewerten
die unterschiedlichen Süssspeisen.
* Gelassene Loungeklänge *
Es war speziell,
sie haben nicht gross geredet.
Ich bin nicht sicher,
ob es angekommen ist.
Dann geht es richtig los.
2'000 Dessert-Fans haben sich Tickets
für die Veranstaltung gekauft.
Hi.
Auf der Veranstaltung
wollen die Schweizer
ihr Waffelangebot bekannter machen.
Ihr Plan scheint aufzugehen:
Die Konkurrenz um den Titel
des Dessert Champions ist gross.
Zwei Preise
werden am Ende des Events vergeben.
Die Preise gehen an andere.
Mike und Marina sind nach einem Tag
mit vollem Einsatz geschafft.
Wir haben es genossen.
Man merkt, dass die Amerikaner,
wie soll ich sagen,
aus etwas so Kleinem
eine Riesensache machen können.
Man hat gemerkt, dass sie auf
Süssigkeiten, auf Desserts abfahren.
Und was mir v.a. wichtig ist:
Es waren 1'000 oder 1'500 Bewerber.
50 dürfen teilnehmen
und wir sind Teil dieser 50.
Also besser kann es nicht sein
nach einem Jahr in Tampa.
* Rumbaversion von Göläs
"Uf u Dervo" *
Schau, jetzt arbeitet José gerade.
Bauer Sandro, ganz Ökonom,
hat sich einen automatischen
Futteranschieber geleistet.
Das ist
mein günstigster Mitarbeiter.
Durch den Roboter
spart er nicht nur Zeit -
seine Tiere
bekommen auch mehr Futter.
Und somit steigt der Milchertrag.
* Melancholische Akkordeonklänge *
Durch den Kauf
des riesigen Hofs Les Aubiers
wurde die Wiesers quasi über Nacht
zu einem der grössten
Milchproduzenten der Gegend.
Die Vorbesitzer
blieben als Mitarbeiter auf dem Hof.
Das war Teil des Deals.
Patrice Rondeau,
der mittlere der drei Brüder,
half Sandro v.a. in der Anfangszeit.
Patrice wird auf dem Hof bleiben -
bis zu seiner Pensionierung
in zweieinhalb Jahren.
Allez! C'est parti.
Cyrille, der jüngste der Brüder,
war vor dem Verkauf
für die Zucht zuständig.
Er kümmert sich weiterhin
um die Kühe und das Melken.
Hop, hop.
Durch den Umzug mit ihren Tieren
nach Frankreich
setzten die Wiesers
alles auf eine Karte.
Hier an der Atlantikküste
erhoffte sich Sandro mehr
unternehmerische Freiheiten.
Zwischenbilanz
nach dem ersten Jahr ist:
Wir haben in gewissen Bereichen
einen Haufen Lehrgeld bezahlt.
Anderes Klima,
andere Witterungsverhältnisse.
Wir mussten uns auch ein wenig
adaptieren, aber durchwegs positiv.
Wir haben einen Riesenvorteil,
indem die Vorbesitzer hier arbeiten.
So gewinnen wir Zeit.
Man muss keine Sachen suchen.
Aber es sind natürlich auch
festgefahrene Modelle.
Ich sage immer:
"Cassez les habitudes."
Ja.
Ich muss die Vorgänge und Abläufe
zwischendurch aufbrechen,
damit wir wieder
einen Schritt vorwärtskommen.
Z.B. José
und die Technologisierung ...
Da habe ich manchmal
ein wenig mit ihnen zu kämpfen.
Aber im übersichtlichen Rahmen.
Und der Rest?
Das war eine gute Entscheidung.
Ich habe im Leben schon viele
schlechte Entscheidungen getroffen,
aber die gehört nicht dazu.
Gell, Mädchen.
Mmh, ist es gut?
Ouef, ouef, que lac je.
Was?
Ei, Ei, was sehe ich.
Ouef, ouef, que lac je.
* Gian lacht. *
Also, ich habe es verstanden.
Familie Wieser
hat ihr Schicksal erfolgreich
in die eigenen Hände genommen
und ihr Glück in Frankreich gefunden.
Winterthur Anfang Januar 2022.
Es kann sein, dass sie baden geht.
Sie kennt nichts.
Rund zwei Monate ist es her, dass
sich Evas ehemaliger Partner Philippe
aus dem Projekt
in der Toskana zurückgezogen hat.
Wie ist das Wasser?
Super.
Nach reiflicher Überlegung
hat sich Eva nun dazu entschlossen,
das Agriturismo in Italien
zu verkaufen.
Es geht mir sehr gut
mit dieser Entscheidung.
Ich habe durch die Zeit
und das Erlebnis dort unten gemerkt,
dass mir andere Sachen wichtig sind.
die dort nicht vorhanden sind.
So gesehen bin ich auf
der einen Seite auch sehr dankbar,
dass ich diese Erfahrung
machen konnte,
und weiss,
dass das nicht das Richtige ist.
Offen sein
und immer wieder Neues ausprobieren.
Das macht für Eva das Leben aus.
Und wenn es schief geht,
versucht sie,
das Positive aus den gemachten
Erfahrungen mitzunehmen.
So auch aus dem Auswanderungsprojekt
mit Philippe.
Das war
keine erprobte Partnerschaft.
Es gab ganz viele Fragezeichen.
Und das würde ich
nicht mehr so machen.
Ich würde sagen, das ist auch naiv.
Ich bin wahrscheinlich,
teilweise naiv im Sinne von:
Es kommt alles gut.
Es kommt immer alles gut.
Und auf der anderen Seite
habe ich jetzt so gemerkt,
dass ich vielleicht genauer auf mich
und meine eigenen Bedürfnisse,
meine eigenen Ideen hören sollte.
Ja ...
Alles begann damit,
dass Eva einen Teil ihres
Riegelhauses in Winterthur verkaufte.
Damit finanzierte sie
die Liegenschaft in der Toskana.
Schon kurz nach dem Start
ging die Beziehung mit ihrem Partner
Philippe in die Brüche.
Auf freundschaftlicher Basis
versuchten sie,
das Agriturismo
zum Laufen zu bringen.
Eva als Geldgeberin,
Philippe als Gutsverwalter.
Doch zu unterschiedlich
waren die Vorstellungen,
zu gross die Probleme.
Aber auch wenn es diesmal
nicht geklappt hat,
das Thema Auswandern
ist für die 67-Jährige
noch längst nicht abgeschlossen.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
einfach hier zu Hause zu sitzen,
dreimal am Tag
mit dem Hund rauszugehen
und ganz viele Bücher zu lesen.
Und was mache ich?
Das ist mir einfach zu langweilig,
da bin ich nicht gefordert,
da bin ich nicht ...
Ich will etwas Sinnvolles machen
und zwar so lange ich kann.
Solange ich Kraft und Energie habe,
will ich einfach weitermachen.
* Gelassene Gitarrenklänge *
Das ist auch schön.
Das ist in Frankreich.
Das fängt schon an
Geschichten zu erzählen.
In Tampa geniessen Marina und Mike
einen freien Nachmittag am Meer.
Das ist arschkalt.
Ja, es ist kühler als auch schon.
- Nicht?
Bald zwei Jahre
leben sie bereits in den USA.
Eine Zeit, die durch viel Arbeit
und den Aufbau ihres
Waffelrestaurants geprägt war.
Gehen wir nach vorne?
Für mich war immer klar, wenn wir
auswandern und ein Business starten,
dass die ersten Paar Jahre
heftiger werden als in der Schweiz.
Also ich bin nicht
mit der Einstellung gegangen,
dass wir mehr Freizeit
als in der Schweiz haben.
Mit dieser Einstellung
bin ich nicht ...
(Beide) Sind wir nicht gekommen.
Aber das ist unsere Vision,
wir sind noch nicht dort,
wo wir hinwollen.
Das ist so.
Dazu gehört mehr Freizeit
und weniger Arbeit.
Irgendwann
ist es mehr Genuss als Arbeit.
Mhm.
Aber nicht jetzt,
es ist noch zu früh.
Marina und Mike wagten viel,
als sie die Schweiz verliessen.
Die Coronakrise
erschwerte ihnen den Start.
Schliesslich konnten sie
ihr Waffelrestaurant eröffnen
und das Geschäft lief immer besser.
Aber die hohe Arbeitsbelastung
machte Mike krank.
Mit Durchhaltewillen und Zuversicht
haben sie auch diese Krise
gemeinsam gemeistert.
Es hat uns nähergebracht.
Wir sind noch vertrauter als vorher.
Wir sind anders,
wir sind stärker geworden.
Man schützt sich gegenseitig,
man kennt die Schwächen des anderen.
Man greift sicher auch mehr ein
und agiert füreinander.
Man weiss:
Wenn der andere an ein Limit kommt,
bin ich dran,
jetzt muss ich hervortreten.
Ich habe gemerkt,
dass sie sehr stark ist.
Als ich ausgefallen bin,
was sie alles gemanagt
und gemacht hat ...
Das kann und macht nicht jeder.
Ja, das ist sicher eine Seite,
die ich noch weniger kannte.
Wie stark sie eigentlich ist.
Allen Schwierigkeiten zum Trotz
haben sich Marina und Mike in Florida
etwas aufgebaut.
Ich würde es zu 100 % wieder machen.
Ja. 100 %.
- Ich auch, definitiv.
Auch wenn wir jetzt nicht hier
wären, wo wir sind,
hätten wir es wenigstens probiert.
Es ist nicht so,
dass wir dann versagt hätten.
Wir haben uns für diesen Weg
in unserem Leben entschieden.
Wenn der Weg nicht stimmen würde,
hätten wir schon lange
einen anderen Weg eingeschlagen.
* Marina lacht. *
* Gemütliche Klänge *
Irgendwann ein Häuschen kaufen,
ein schönes Plätzchen einrichten.
Ich möchte irgendwann ein Boot.
Oh mein Gott.
Ich hätte lieber einen zweiten Hund.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Michaela Hoss - 2022